nice it's my my absolute pleasure to
announce the the final keynote of of
today this day went by really fast for
me I hope same for you um the the origin
of this keynote is actually back in back
in 2019 uh there was this really nice
social network um and on this social
network I saw a message from mukash and
mukash is one of the core maintainers of
uh of python he offered a couple of peps
that you're probably familiar with and
it was it was this picture and and this
is a picture of the of the Night Watch
probably most of you will recognize it
everyone that's from Amsterdam will for
sure recognize it and it basically said
there's this camera with this giant rig
at the re's Museum on the night watch
and there's a laptop in front that's
running like it's running python it's a
Jupiter notebook and there's map plot on
this and lo and M hold the first
reaction was was Rob and oh that's me
yeah this is Jupiter an AC in Koo and
there's a red button that that quits the
entire thing if something breaks and I
just thought like the stars have aligned
this is the pataa Amsterdam keynote for
next time we have an inperson event so
it's my pleasure to Welcome to the stage
Rob Erman full professor at the UA
scientist at the re Museum please give
him a large round of
[Applause]
[Music]
applause
uh well thank you very much um thanks
for the the invitation I'm really
excited to to finally uh be back among
the Nerds again um yeah so that tweet
ended up um resulting in UMO rosum um
talking about how heartwarming it was to
see that his um async iio has was being
used for something so um so momentous as
the night watch and then I got an
invitation to be a keynote speaker at
the Pyon conference which then didn't
happen because of covid and then a year
passed and I uh I was able to give a a
keynote about the Imaging of the night
watch but um the conference was online
only so this is my first opportunity to
be back among um python developers I'm
not going to talk about that though um
I'm I'll I'll talk about the results of
it um but um rather I hope during the
next uh 50 minutes or so to to give you
a sense uh I guess 45 minutes to give
you a sense of the kinds of um really
interesting work on computation and
imaging uh that I get to do as senior
scientist in the reiches museum um I'm
also a professor at the University of
Amsterdam split between um physics and
the faculty of Science and conservation
and restoration um so broadly I Define
my mission as to help the world access
preserve and understand its cultural
heritage um and when I first uh came to
the reiches museum I was a fluid
mechanics guy my PhD is in Material
Science so I was really not a cultural
heritage um person so far so when I came
to the field I recognized that there are
certain things that we could use from
high performance Computing and so on to
help the field um and I made a 10-year
plan in 2014 so I'm on year 9 of the
10-year plan to try to build the things
that I think the field needs um so this
is a slide from my Pon talk in 2021 that
shows um the Absurd links that I had to
go to to image the night watch which
again is uh it's REM Brand's largest
painting um and it's uh the re museum is
actually designed as a kind of Cathedral
around um around the night watch it's at
the center of the gallery of honor and
so on um so I'll just U show you the
kinds of things um that I had to deal
with to take a picture and that's that's
um uh to take a really really really big
picture so this is the night watch in
the reiches museum and you can see
there's a big glass box around it and
the reason for this is that about a
quarter uh to half of the people who go
to the reich's museum come explicitly to
see the night watch so if we're going to
do a research project and a a
restoration project for the painting
called operation Night Watch we can't
take it off display and put it in the
lab and go work on it we have to do
everything in front of the public so
that's a huge challenge um so uh to do
that that um the first stage was a
research project in which we had to
basically collect all of the data we
possibly could about the painting and
that includes an incredibly high
resolution um photo so we had to uh
design and program a five AIS robot that
can move left right up down front back
and to rotate around the painting um
because we want to take a picture that's
uh 5 micrometer resolution and what that
means is if you move one pixel to the
right in your image you're moving 5
micrometers to the right in in the image
and a human red blood cell has a
diameter of 8 micrometers so one of our
pixels will happily fit inside a human
red blood
cell so we have a robot and we Mount the
world's highest resolution camera on
this thing that can move around in front
of the
painting uh we have um lasers and Flash
units and all kinds of things to measure
distances
um and then to take a huge picture like
this you first have to know what the
true shape of the painting is so this
involves um taking standing really far
back and taking the whole taking a
picture where the whole painting is in
the field of view then you um U measure
the actual distances between all of the
corners every pawise distance and the
diagonal distances and then you can use
um uh pyit learn um to basically
optimize a model to um uh distort the
image so that it's as true to correct
scale as as
possible um then we had laser
rangefinders and I drove around for 4
days in front of the painting with laser
rangefinders to get a a ground truth 3D
model of the the
picture um so the night watch is not
flat um it's basically got a belly it's
a big painting it weighs 300 kg so uh
you can imagine that the the weight of
the paint actually causes the whole
thing to Sag and it's been stretched so
it has Ripples and my camera only has
a a 1/8 of a MM depth of field meaning
the region in space in front of the
camera that will be really really sharp
is only8 of a millimeter thick so if the
painting is like this and my camera is
like this then the overlap between what
is sharp and where the painting is is
only a little strip so I need to
position my camera perfectly so that
everything is
sharp um so there was lots of
calibration um s kit learned stuff real
time fitting then there was a whole
whole bunch of stuff with color color
calibration you take a picture of uh a
Target that has 140 patches with a known
color very very precisely measured color
and then um you know what the truth was
of those colors and then you know what
you saw on your camera so you can
basically build a machine learning model
to transfer what the camera sees into
the truth of what it should see because
why are we capturing the night watch at
5 micrometer resolution because it's the
most important painting in the reiches
museum and sometimes bad things happen
not tradon burns down or there are
terrorist attacks or there are Wars bad
things happen so the act of documenting
our cultural heritage is one of the most
important things plus it's going to be
used for deciding how we're going to
treat the
painting so um bespoke models were made
for color management to correct the
colors from what we saw to what they
should be um then you have this um
absurdly complicated capture system that
basically requires that I have um up
here uh a Raspberry Pi that's got a
microcontroller that knows how to drive
the camera all over the place plus it
has accelerometers because I want to
wait till the camera is not bouncing
around to take a picture it has
temperature and relative humidity
because things change their shape and
size when things get moist and when
things get hot um I have a laptop that
rides around with the camera and I need
to tell the camera to take picture but
the camera at this at this time um
doesn't have an API so I had to make a
screen reader that could simulate typing
on the buttons and you know typing file
names and so on um and then as soon as I
take a picture I had to do um a realtime
quality checking with a neural network
that would see whether the photo I had
just taken was appropriately lit whether
it was sharp whether it had motion blur
all of this kind of stuff so um I have
to take
8,439 photos
driving this camera all over the place
and if I take a bad photo I'll be really
sad later after I tear everything down
and I find that one of the photos is bad
so there's real time um neural network
uh uh uh binary classification yay or n
um on the
laptop um and then there is an async iio
Jupiter interface so I can sit in a
Jupiter notebook that has um iPie
widgets running connected to the robot
in real time while I'm sitting there
typing away in cells so all of these
buttons that you see here this is just a
Jupiter
notebook that has iPie
widgets running in one of my cells real
time because whenever you're in Jupiter
you actually have the async iio loop
already running so you can just throw
things in there and and they'll work and
you can sit there and do your
computations that you would normally be
doing interactively while it's
constantly doing websockets talking to
the back end to make sure that the robot
is
Happy um yeah so then you you collect um
lots and lots of data um I was inspired
to get into computer Graphics because I
loved lightbrite as a child so this this
meme really Struck it for me um we're
making a an image that's going to be 717
gigapixels so you collect 7 terab of
data image data and then you have to
stitch them all together so how does
that work um here is a little zoom in of
the main
figure
um each one of these is a 100 megapixel
photo so I have to stitch these all
together um so that there's no evidence
that this came from a camera with a
painting that's moving because it's a
17.2 met sail there's air currents in
the reiches museum and so the painting
moves back into and forth very very
slowly and I have an eighth of a
millimeter window that I have to capture
correctly um so there's one of my photos
so I take that overview photo that I
collected at the beginning Where I Stood
way back and took a picture of the whole
thing and then I have to uh register my
little photo onto that so I know where
it sits that involves a neural network
that learns how to filter images
regardless of their Source or their
resolution so that I can find uh
precisely
the one offset that would make them line
up
perfectly um then I measure that offset
field across the images then I model it
again scikit learn uh with a robust
estimator to figure out exactly what
kind of perspective effects and so on I
need um and then down the rabbit hole do
this at more
resolutions and then ultimately I I have
an idea of where I should put each of
these
8,439 100 megapixel photos but I need to
do it really fast so then Jax comes in
um which ultimately lets you write
really simple codes so like here's the
code for an interpolation kernel and
here's the code to apply a the
interpolation kernel to figure out the
color so this is um 7 by7 querying if I
I need to know what color it is
someplace where I didn't measure a a
pixel then I'm looking at a 7x7
neighborhood to figure out what the
color function looks like so that I can
do a really really really good job of
interpolation where I want to know the
the image uh color um so with Jax you
can just write that with uh querying to
one point and then you can say hey why
don't you just map this across all of
the axes so that I'm going to query at
100 million points and ultimately you
can do that so that your your
interpolation function runs in 44
milliseconds for 100 million
pixels that's
important um because you've got a lot of
pixels um so pandas is involved behind
the scenes to keep track of all the
metadata and where things go and their
file names and everything else and then
there's a bunch of graph Theory um to
figure out how to stitch this together
without going okay I have no images I
put one down okay and now I have another
image and now I make a stitch with two
images okay now I have another one and I
make a stitch with three images you
can't do that because then it would take
till the end of the world so instead you
you make a a color partition of the
overlap graph of all of the images into
four in this case four colors so I have
four um nonoverlapping sets that look
like this um So within any given set
none of the images overlap but if I can
figure out how to fuse together these
four Images then I will have one Fusion
of the whole thing but then the quality
of the pixels at the edge of an image
are lower than the quality of the pixels
at the center of the image because then
you have lens Distortion because you're
probing the sides of the lens you have
um color aberration you have vignetting
so I need to fuse together the data in a
way that weights the pixels at the
center more heavily than the pixels at
the edge so that means I have to do uh
solve a pan equation and so I use the pi
AMG algebraic multi-grid solver to solve
the pon equation for the pixel weighting
at each
pixel um then they get fused together
and then I'm using scale space which is
a beautiful area of mathematics that
basically says that an image like this
one here on the left can be decomposed
as if you blur it a little bit you get
this one but then what did you take away
the difference is these this thing down
here so this represents only the
smallest features the larger features
the larger features the larger features
and the largest features so I can
basically do surgery on an image and I
blend the small features together out of
small scale blend the medium features
together out of medium scale blend the
large features together at a large scale
and that means that any variations that
I might have because my left light was
always brigh than my right light by 4%
or something when I'm going from one
image to the one next to it to the one
next to it those broad lighting
gradients get blurred
away in the end um these are pixel
coordinates um down here so it's
basically a million pixels wide 77,000
pixels
tall great so uh that was the talk I
gave at Pon uh 2021 so now I'm going to
tell you about what kinds of things we
can do with an image like
that um so I'll show you some examples
to begin with so here it is um and down
at the lower right corner I'm going to
put in a scale bar so the actual
painting is 4 and half meters wide and
3.7 met tall
okay so let's zoom into something that I
know is
beautiful
so here we are um that's 500 micrometers
so that's half a millimeter over there
I'm now able to see every single pigment
particle um and in fact I can measure
the the diameter of this here um that's
only 1.3 mm
wide so I can now see the paint before
that Rembrandt thought he had mixed
completely on his pette I can see the
three streaks of
paint
um I can see a smt particle which is a
little it's a kind of pigment that's
made of cobalt that's ground up Cobalt
glass that's ground up um and so I can
see the fragmentation P pattern of the
of the Cobalt um if I zoom into um what
is uh often um thought to be a rembrand
self-portrait this guy here wearing the
Beret peeking between the two um then I
I get to study um what's um is sometimes
called the mystery of Mastery how does
REM Brandt know that if he does three
little strokes of paint like this
that when I zoom out to here it will
look like a highlight on his eye so so
is this just like the cult of resolution
that I like really like pixels um I do
really like pixels but um here you can
see the kinds of things that we would be
interested in from a conservation
standpoint this is what's called a lead
soap lead soap happens when you um when
you have um lead that's in for example
the oil paint or the ground layer behind
the painting um uh lead white is a is a
paint it's often used in in these times
that reacts with potassium it under go a
saponification reaction and it makes a
little little particle which over
hundreds of years gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and it pokes its head on the
surface of the of the uh painting like a
pimple and then so here's one that's
poked its head out and then later it
will fall out leaving behind a crater
that then fills with dirt and this
discolors the appearance of the painting
um the other kinds of stuff I can do
here um I can see evidence of the of the
past conservation treatments so here's
the the only woman in the whole painting
uh famously and if I zoom all the way in
here again there's 250 micrometers scale
bar um I can see a place where in 1975
or 76 a restorer made a tiny little 1 mm
wide dab of paint to cover up this
blemish on her face and back here you
probably don't see it but it's there we
can see
it um other uh cool things we can do for
example um since I have this neural
network uh image registration system I
can show you a photo of the uh damage
from the slashing attack in 1975 a
Madman um came up with a knife and
started slashing at the at the main
figure um and some other figures um and
I can also show you a manganes map which
is obtained from uh procedure called
macro x-ray fluoresence where we
basically shoot X-rays at a painting we
measure the x-rays that come off the
so-called fluorescent x-rays we we
measure their energies and we can map
the elements across the whole painting
so here you have the 5 microm uh
resolution uh image you have a photo
from 1975 where it was uh slashed and
you have the map of the manganes which
is indicative of a pigment called Umber
and the restorers used umber to to
repair the painting but Ram brand did
not use umber so when I see manganese I
know aha that's not Ram brand
also you can see up here that there is a
little uh kind of carou that has the
names of the sitters rembrand didn't
paint that um and you can further see
that someone made a boo
boo um and so there's a kind of Tex
correction that I can see over
there um we don't only work with
paintings so here's a beautiful object
that was just purchased by the reiches
museum with a very generous donation um
this is a a kind of glass called kungl
glass um so this was um photographed
completely by robots so here you have
um 500 photos um so I basically bought
an Ikea turntable and hooked up a
stepper motor to it and then put a fast
API uh interface on it in Python um and
I also have the ability to control a
camera from python so I can put the
object on the turntable take a picture
turn it one 500th of a turn take a
picture and so on um but then the
problem with an object like this is that
it's um it has no center it's totally
lopsided so if you put it on the
turntable and you take pictures then it
goes like this so this also has behind
the scenes um from from meta they've
released something called the segment
anything model Sam um so this is using
the segment anything model to se segment
the foreground from the background and
then to basically correct it so that the
the the only symmetric part on the
object which is the stem stays perfectly
centered on a cell phone if you come to
me afterwards it's cool because I hooked
up the Tilt sensor so it's like a
virtual object you can tilt your phone
and you can see different sides of
it um sometimes what you want is a
display in which uh you need more frames
than you took but you can't just average
between your frames because then
everything would become blurry so this
is using something called frame
interpolation so basically if I have uh
let's say 360 photos one degre separated
then I can teach a neural network how to
um infer missing photos so I can say ah
well I pretend that I only have 180
photos and I ask you to guess the even
numbered ones and I know the answer so I
teach you how to how to guess what those
are and then I keep uh subdividing so I
have 360 photos I ask it to guess the
ones that would have been at the half
deegree increments and now I have 720
photos I repeat that I have 1400 and so
on down the rabbit hole um so this this
is 3,000 photos coming from only 500 um
so that I can play it back just butter
smooth on on a website for
example um we can also do cool things
because of this registration and the
ability to automatically move a
turntable um here is an object from the
hollandia Shipwreck um the re museum is
the Dutch national museum of art and
history so we have a lot of history
objects um and so this is the same kind
of thing but also I have the ability to
move move a
light um I should also say that 100% of
what I'm showing you here is running in
in my web browser so none of this is
logo this is just a web
browser
um uh yeah so this then gives us the
ability to use our our um human
perceptual um psychology we have
incredible ability to infer The Shapes
of Things by looking at how the shading
changes when when they the when the
angle changes so even though I don't
have a 3D model that I'm showing you
here this is just photos um the fact
that I'm able to smoothly blend between
photos where the light was at different
positions means that you probably have a
really excellent idea of what shape this
thing is with these beautiful scroll
Engravings and so
on
um so uh more traditional neural network
stuff um that's a silver object and in
the 17th century if you were a a a
master silver maker when you made a
piece of silver you would stamp your
maker mark on it and then it would go to
the guild and they would assay it to
make sure it was you know really 14
karat gold that kind of stuff um they
would make sure it was the right uh
grade of silver and they would uh um
they would put their own stamp on it
that says what year it was assayed and
so on so this is a little um uh neural
network in which I can upload an image
in this case I just have it on my um on
my hard drive but you could do this with
a cell phone you upload load an image
and then through a fast API and then a p
torch neural network that's running
inside the fast API back end here um I
can basically bring up uh an estimate of
which Makers Mark or tax Mark or
whatever this is so in this case it
thinks it's a maker mark from yonas Gua
um and it's super duper confident that
that's the right answer and it also
shows you examples of that maker Mark so
it doesn't just tell you the answer it
basically gives an expert the ability to
assess what they think is a good idea
um uh moving on now to a a beautiful
uh drawing by rembrand this is only 14
cm tall uh people think that it's
probably of his wife although his wife
saskia who died the year the r the night
watch was finished uh was too high class
to ever dress like a peasant like this
but um still um what I've done here is
taken raking light photos so that's
basically you have a flashlight or torch
um and you shine it at different angles
across the surface so I've basically
fused those together and then um used
machine learning to assess how much of
what we see here is due to the color of
the paper and how much it was due to the
shading the to the uh the surface
topology of the paper and now what I can
do is have a virtual light source that's
attached to the
mouse that I can now move the mouse
around in front of this drawing and show
you what it would look like if it had no
color so this is basically if it were
made of chalk what would it look like
and you can see that now I can see
beautiful details like I can see that
rembrand apparently used a different pen
here for these scribbles I can see the
chain lines and the laid lines from the
mold I can see where it's had
conservation treatments I can see how
the ink has caused at this big stroke
that you see here how the ink has caused
the paper to pucker up because of the
hydrogen bonds between the paper fibers
I really get a sense of how REM brand
Drew this thing I can almost reconstruct
the stroke order we're not there yet but
um by using physically based rendering
um this is worked with a PhD student of
mine uh alisandra
Mary um we can basically simulate the
process of lighting this object with
raking light and then we can ask well
what elevation of the paper would make
the photos that we actually saw you know
like so I can simulate where the lights
were where the camera was and then I can
use um differential programming
differentiable programming rather um to
basically figure out what elevation of
the paper would have when photographed
in the way that I photographed it with
all these raking lights given me the
photos that I took so that that then
really lets you see where the paper is
so light color is close to us dark color
is far away from
us um now uh one of my favorite examples
here is okay you got to work on paper
and the work on paper has um a watermark
in it and that will tell you who made
the who made the paper um so great hold
it up to the light and then what you see
is all of the ink because it's a piece
of paper in the museum so it's got
something really great on the front and
often on the back so I want to see The
Watermark what do I do uh well you you
train a neural network to remove the ink
um so here is another little fast APA
server where I can drag and drop images
into it um and then it um it uses a
synthetic data set that I use physics to
simulate how how it looks when ink gets
added to paper I basically take that and
I reverse it to make it as a training
set for a convolutional neural network
so this goes in and this uh this comes
out so this goes in it takes away all of
the ink so that goes in takes away all
of the ink this comes out and now you
can read The
Watermark this goes
in this comes out now you can read The
Watermark so then we can identify who
who made this where was the paper made
and uh can we can we then say something
interesting about the
artwork um let's see I'm going to skip
ahead a little bit um here is um
beautiful 5 micrometer Imaging um that
our photographer Cora van VI and I
collected same kind of
thing uh but here we didn't have a robot
that could tilt because the robot that
can tilt is still in front of the night
watch um so if you would go here you can
see that some places this this one
shouldn't be sharp but as an example
this one's not sharp so we can use um a
super resolution
style um Transformer Network to
basically um infer what it would have
looked like if it were sharp so this
goes in this comes out and suddenly you
can see these
details um when we collect macro x-ray
fluoresence data we usually get
something like this in the middle so
this is phosphorus map and you can see
that it's really it's really spotty this
is a low concentration element that's
very difficult to detect but there is
something that images are like this is
not a pointless painting this is this
has brush Strokes so knowing that it has
brush Strokes then based upon what I
sense I can figure out what the what the
probably correct distribution of
phosphorus is so this is a neural
network that takes this very very noisy
data and effectively denises it under a
pan data model to tell us what it would
have looked like over here
um we don't just collect the data we can
also do cool things to analyze it so
this is Martin and opion this is a pair
of portraits that were purchased for
um 80 million
each um by the French and Dutch
governments they now hang in the reiches
museum and they will hang in the Lou
reiches Museum Lou alternating every
eight years from now until eternity
under a treaty agreement these are the
only full length portrait that R Brandt
portraits that R Brandt painted so um if
you would take an x-ray of this you
would see that it's painted on canvas
and mostly what you see in an x-ray of a
painting is where is the lead white
where are the heavy elements in the
paint but you can also see very very
very faintly the imprint of the canvas
so it's you know it's a woven texture so
if I can suppress everything else and
just show you the canvas then if I can
make a map of the spacing between the
threads then the spacing between the
threads is a unique fingerprint of that
one roll of canvas so if you know look
at your jeans and you'll see that
there's a dark fiber there's a white
light fiber that's only there's only one
piece of cloth in the whole world that
has that pattern so when I detect that I
can tell that they were cut from the
same Ro of canvas so if there was any
question about whether these two really
belonged together uh no no question I
can also look at the angle of the of the
threads in the canvas and I can see
evidence for how they were originally
stretched when they were being prepared
so I can see that they used to be
stitched together before they were
before they were uh
separate um now moving to
something uh bigger zooming out uh this
is now a bit stale this is from 2016 but
I was really excited when RES Nets came
out and so on um it seemed like the
final um the the penultimate layer
before the classification head on a
neural network would be feature uh Rich
at a high semantic level so what I did
was I took every one of the 177,000
works on paper in the reiches museum I
ran them through this neural network
asked the neural network to give me a
feature Vector that's I think 248
Dimensions here and then I used tne as
well as my own algorithm to squeeze the
results of a tne clustering into a
rectangle um to show every single work
on paper with no metadata where the
network has put things that it thinks
are semantically similar near each other
so for example if I zoom in you can see
it's decided to put all of Rembrandt's
etchings yeah it's full
resolution uh together in one place I
can see that um all of the you know Farm
animals are all
together I can see up here that there's
you know lots
of scenes with Bridges and architecture
and and so on so this is this is 177,000
Works in one place because the thing is
that a lot of people go to the museum
website they don't know what they're
looking for they just you know like a
vermier um and rembrand but like how do
I know all the cool things that are in
the re Museum well this shows you all of
them um
um finally um coming to the final
stretch now um there is a a paper that's
um sort of the basis of all of this you
know stable diffusion generative AI kind
of stuff called clip contrastive um
learning um uh uh sorry contrastive
language image pre-training and the
super cool thing that people don't
really talk about is that what this um
this clip network is all about is a
joint embedding and that joint embedding
means um that um I have a bunch of
images that have um to train it I have a
bunch of images that have captions so
they basically sucked up you know uh 400
million images from the internet with
captions with you know like the alt text
and wherever you could find a caption um
and um the network knows how to
associate images with captions and the
way that it does this the super cool
thing about this is that there is one
embedding space one latent space where
it has two doors you can come in with an
image
you bring an image and it gives you a
1536 dimensional Vector that's a feature
Vector that's a place in this latent
space or you come with some English text
and it puts you in the same space so
this means that now uh you have a way of
comparing images and text so what I did
was I took 2.3 Open Access 2.3 million
Open Access images um I ran them each
through this um Network so I have 2.3
million points here and then I built a
search engine
um that lets me uh type what I'm looking
for like a woman
wearing
sorry uh blue holding a musical
instrument oops
sorry and instantly get a
result um a colorful
staircase and you can query at points
that are off the the space of images so
for example um a
medieval uh
laptop or meta
evil
airplane you can also do amazing things
with this for example a Blan
Shard A blon Shard painting of Paris
blon Shard was a was an impressionist
oops of
Paris uh was an impressionist painter
who painted lots and lots and lots of
images of of Paris so what I can do is
say okay that's nice but I want to also
carry by image so I'll copy the image
address so I'll just put in a URL and it
will look up the image and find
similarities that way okay so there's a
bunch of images that it thinks are
semantically relevant to this but then I
can also say all right that's nice
that's nice but I want to move in this
High dimensional semantic space in the
snow Direction so I'm starting at an
image and I want to lean in some
Direction that's given by language so
let's move in this snow Direction and
see what's
nearby or how about I move in the um
warm glowing Cafe lights
Direction and now I find images that
start here in the space and that then
drift in the warm glowing Cafe lights
struction um so I will finish up um with
what I think is the most fun
demonstration I'm going to skip some
things because of time but um so this is
all great but um I want something where
I can walk around in a museum and point
my phone at something and have it tell
me what what I'm looking at and show me
other things in other Musea so um this
is a this is a new app that I'm working
on on that I Call Serendipity and what
I'm going to do here is I have a webcam
and I have an art history book The Story
of art so I'm going to point the webcam
at this um all python uh backed with
fast
API
so um whatever I point the webcam at
it's searching four times per second so
if I'm going to you know pointed at
this bearded old bastard or plants or
how about I point it at an art history
book so this is showing the top 24 most
similar results in this data database of
2.3 million Open Access images four
times a second
remotely and it works just as well on
your cell phone but a cell phone doesn't
do well over the
projector so um with that um I guess I
will I will leave it there and to say
that the big picture is that we can
really um find a huge number of
incredibly cool incredibly hard problems
in the museum and and um it has big
impact because if we succeed then we can
help the world access preserve and
understand its cultural heritage thank
[Applause]
you